Merry Christmas - Merry Christmas -
dukes
you got me yes I got you thank you read
the note person yeah
- my favorite little drummer it will
always be my favorite small acne covered
beans
Oh your small land covered you got a
seat
yeah lots of it dude yeah I do have that
Wow yeah I drummed you're like a little
baby yeah when I see you I think of a
baby yeah I got a gift for you to mark
you roll
you should open it up man all right
thank you so much that's so good
I'm sick of the jokes mark in the videos
I laugh I laugh out loud but on the
inside on the inside I'm crying it was
just a goof it was a gaffe it was a goof
all their jokes hurt mark they hurt real
bad and now you're gonna feel some pain
- Merry Christmas mark ha ha ha ha
change hi guys welcome to the may be new
challenge we're going to be doing in
Prague this is where we play the game
called change we're going to get a
suggestion to do a normal improv scene
and whoever sitting here gets to say the
word change and when you hear the word
change you have to change exactly why
you sit right you have to jump up down
scream like a balloon your word my
inspiration is hope I hope the fall
harvest is better for this year we're
going to die James oh my gosh James
follow the Badgers they're back the
badges they always take our pride to
surprise their wives
James oh my ass to get all dog on oh let
me take a look
Cheers I don't want to see that James
wow that's really there no it's gone oh
what's that
yeah your right leg seem to go what
about the Badgers let's go there three
oh they're shin visible [ __ ] visible
their [ __ ] invisible their mala we know
they come for our [ __ ] I hate how we
don't they come for our man change
hemorrhoids must suck
oh I've got so many problems
Badgers hemorrhoids crops wives
[ __ ] ate one James lease I'm not one
change right life sucks
James give me you me up how can you
dance at a time like this
my name's Cheryl change my name is poopy
pants
my name is McDouble I'm a woman oh I
didn't notice it first telling you oh
man I am suspected for years well I
shouldn't know when I was knee-deep in
those boobs there I fear I can see them
can I squeeze why I'm sure can no I'll
do anything baby I guess change there's
some moves at all they were fake bad
news for they were bad oh good okay go
what do you do about the other woman it
likes you
James it's already eating you Jade oh my
god it's huge
thank you that's not as his herb I'm not
sure what pronoun you use I'm going to
be very PG and social justice II won't
dare you him per Jesum just hit double
just boom okay well uh hmm well you
couldn't stop him from the harness you
couldn't study from up well you couldn't
stop him from like directing a Mahna
Mahna Mahna Mahna Mahna ma I'm out of
stroke I don't know what to do for you
but perhaps James here ate this radish
James we have crop
know what to do anymore hey would you
like my pets how's that going to help me
and you one move no move MacDougall I'm
so confused this farm is going to [ __ ]
look who's arriving aliens are invading
Oh your mother god damn it we can't take
another crisis in this house as big as
the Badgers are James
I'm gonna [ __ ] your mother okay that
would take us all stay here just watch
with my badger my god I feel like we're
just flipping in between dimensions as
time goes on I don't know where's our
Channing huh but at least I've still got
you mcdougal James at least I've still
got one half of my ass and you know with
one boob in one ass we make a whole
woman that we do let's drop our pants
together and scene all right at the good
part your word of inspiration is memes
at boy in that boy that boy that boy
that boy I want a lot no no we need to
get rid of all James I think you have a
great idea we should collect them change
I think that those pants would look
great with this mean hmm
yeah huh like when you slip those on
right there I look like that boy James I
feel like that boy I am Shia LaBeouf we
gotta just do it we gotta take all the
memes you look more like a hippo and a
pair of corduroy
you look more like me than I thought you
would I do look like you I finally got
that facial hair that I've always wanted
oh [ __ ] what up JD I'm just gonna ride a
trike teenage I got a pogo stick age I
think I'll just stand here and talk to
you some more game different Apple -
Apple change I love that orange rage wow
I really am not hungry I my appetite is
anyway back to the memes I want all of
the means we've got a collective
knowledge this is a trading card game we
have to collect every single mean how
exactly do colectomy you got a capture
with a net got to capture it with a car
we got to hit it with it you have to run
it over with a bicycle I was a lot of
use my bicycle earlier but I guess I
have a good thing I kept them around I
know right this is a tandem so I can get
on the back which one should we go for
first are you ready to pedal with big
change
are you ready to stand here stupidly
pretending with age you like my ass it
looks great now get those likes of
cycling chicken it looks great now get
those get that blood pumping oh this
might take a change I guess I'll just
keep going that uh well there's a quick
healthy huh I don't know it's hardened
oh I think I've got a rig another
bicycle before have we actually been
doing this on camera life change is that
a squirrel
we've hit so many children I think it's
trying to get off those fine
you have to stop swarming all over the
pulpit the bike broke in half change the
bike was jello this whole time never of
the evidence change we have to get rid
of the body change we have to kill your
wife
she's got change your word of
inspiration is care for some money for
your medical procedure Billy change
here's a dildo for your
medical procedures I didn't ask for that
I'm fine I'm 12 look about that change I
just want to be a girl
haha what anything that's the reason I
got you this dildo
no I rather have the money no no does it
make me a girl I need surgery to change
these are bones this is a lady girl test
you I don't know can I touch it
no still 12
got you this dildo change I got you this
hamburger chain got you this really
flame boy hot dog I mean I love the hot
dog it really goes with my outfit but I
smell money girl I need less hot dogs
you take mine I'll trade you I'll eat
that one hold on one change change it
won't come off just pull harder partner
this doesn't seem right away do we doing
though hi Billy
he stopped I don't know you're a doctor
change I don't think you're my uncle I
think you're my uncle
what I don't want you in a Ted again I
just want money so I can get it cut off
and get some folks in an ass I can't
afford that whatever you're Michael I
took it off you talk differently without
the money you have the money the money
turned into the dildo I had to buy it
change the money turn into magical mist
that'll turn you into a girl change the
money was faked
what I mean I could try it like doctors
don't know about money what if I just
man there are other ways to pay in
sexual favors can work I want to be a
girl not a skank perfect see oh my god
that's good your clue is cacti okay so
be very very careful you don't want to
touch the prickers around here they're
very very venomous and if you get
pricked with one all it'll give you a
good sting it'll give you a real good
stick are we looking at plants you know
you say you wanted to come to the
Botanical Garden and this is my favorite
plant right here it's a poisonous cactus
it's very interesting James it's very
pretty
James it's growing small children out of
the bus don't you see that I just can't
anymore you know I just can't with you
you don't listen to me you don't take me
seriously I thought you liked James I
thought you enjoyed flowers all day and
enjoy flowers I thought you wanted to
have children just like this plant is
sprouting you know what you have to do
have children you have to [ __ ] Lloyd if
you want to have kids take me home and
[ __ ] me Sharon that's not always the
option there's thousands of each other
you know what Sharon adoption is always
something that we can do you know
there's so many kids
they're awaiting you know but sprouted
from a plan that plan just abandons them
can swept away in the wind
what about those little look Lance I
know what happened with your parents
traumatize you I know your parents into
this if you're so desperate not to [ __ ]
me then go find some clinic to [ __ ] you
know what Sharon James all right Sharon
ah maybe another plant will want to
spread Sharon I've got a confession
that's my finish like [ __ ] plants
mm-hmm and that's why we haven't had sex
you I guess I'm only into doing it with
points I mean if you're a little bit
more lazy look Lloyd I love you I want
to make a family with you
but so what James I'm into plants too
that's why I've been so mad I'm
frustrated I never knew I thought I
thought I would I was some weirdo that
you know like James I thought that I was
some creep that just changed I thought
that I was the only change do you want
to have sex with a plant with me
no you [ __ ] psychopath I was lying
but why don't you want to do me I do
make babies right here it's just your
your buds you're not you can't even make
kids with a plan stick it in there and
see what happens when you get tricked by
the cabinets children oh yeah I never
wear all over this plan who do you think
inseminated have changed who do you
think they did when sprout I made this
plants proud you said the same three
things Edna James listen Lloyd listen
I'm listening James I'm hearing you okay
I've opened some plans you know what I'm
willing to look past it I think no I
don't get it but that's okay because I
bet you never knew that I was into fire
have you ever noticed how I sort of
unbutton my shirt and you know when we
do the campfire why do you think I
demand that we do campfire six nights a
week through the winter through the
summer matter how cold how hot it is
convenient we can roast Mallos on your
chest so I don't want to be on fire boys
the air fire and what maybe we can get
like a fire pit in the bedroom on my
side and you can have some plants on
your size maybe we can make this work
how close the planets do you need to be
to you know keep it up I need to be in
plant sharing change gotta be on the
other side I want you to [ __ ] the plant
Sharon it's not all about me it is all
about you
plants do nothing for me you said this
one's poisonous most of them are just
floppy leaves water let it turn it on
for you dumb you like danger you like
fire you like playing with fire you'll
play a little bit of poison yeah damn I
you're like getting hit by cars you're
like jumping off a bridge look okay I
was young then I've grown up fires a lot
safer than bridge trumping Jane I I
can't believe those videos are still on
the Internet that's not a sexual thing
it's a dominance thing okay and I'm just
knocking - [ __ ] plants okay I just can't
I can't
that was poisonous right check that
one's purple I can't if you're in the
dominant why don't we just get a [ __ ]
doc let's just get the job you [ __ ]
dog that was hilarious quiet
[Music]